once told you secrets have a cost the
truth does to name that movie that's
that's really vague I mean it sounds
like it could be a bunch of movies come
on man Aunt May says it in the amazing
spider-man 2 oh ok ok see I didn't get
it because you said I once told you
secrets have a cost the truth does too
when the actual quote is I once told you
that secrets have a cost the truth does
too
let's just watch this new rock stars
video new rock stars has a video
spider-man spin-offs sinister six plus
Miles Morales plus spider-gwen question
mark and oh yeah I was supposed to go on
new rock stars rogue theory this week
but because of something going on in the
world yeah they're not allowing guests
in the studio thanks to the cantankerous
vulture welcome back to new rock stars
I'm Erik Bosse welcome back to new
spider-man Robert writer Roberto Orci
yeah wait I think other transformers
[Music]
wouldn't you look at work sleep at work
with these characters it's fine that
Star Trek or two very likely to go for
the upcoming spider-man 3 this news
actually gives us a pretty good
indication of what this spin-off could
be how can I convince you it'll be
talking about spider-man six-burner sir
we got to rewind the clock all the way
back to time-travel or our Lord and
Savior Tom Holland was birthday's
it's all the MCU expanding to new levels
of greatness with Captain America Winter
Soldier and guardians of the galaxy even
today most movies feel so recent and
essential but that same summer so he
attended watch their own movie that
feels kinda like a forgotten past of all
live-action movies with spider-man in
the title it made the least money it got
the worst reviews and it's hope
breakdown Sony that they decided gonna
stand over the piece of the character
the Marvel movie star is Garfield this
Peter Parker Emma Stone as Gwen Stacy
Jamie Foxx is electro and Dane DeHaan as
Harry Osborn Green Goblin is directed by
Marc Webb with its screenplay by Jeff
Pinker Alex Kurtzman and Roberto Orci a
guy writing this next bit off but back
then this trio had collaborated on her
business projects but it was this
amazing spider-man 2 that ended the
partnership Kurtzman wanted to continue
with a third Andrew Garfield Marc Webb
spider-man film while Orsi wanted to
move on to producing directing something
it makes me cringe and if Tony hadn't
been rattled by a cyber attack months
later the Sony spider-verse would have
been a very big deal in our lives the
amazing spider-man 2 ended with a tease
of the arrival of these sinister six
Harry Osborn and I remember that year's
bull abandoned criminals who take over
New York in the absence of spider-man
who was mi a mornings when a feature
like this would have been made up of
Harry Osborn Green Goblin Paul Giamatti
as the Rhino who breaks out of prison in
the final scene in battle spider-man as
well as doc Bulger
Mysterio in Kraven the hunter Roo
Goddard was going to direct this
sinister special only thing that got me
excited about a third plan for it to be
a redemption story that might not even
think ur spider-man and along with a
third Andrew Garfield amazing spider-man
summer 2016
we also would have gotten denim a 2017
black cat movie written by Westworld
co-creator at least a joint NOLA
oh don't realize that a spider-man 2099
film but of course Sony's partnership
with Marvel announced in 2015 dusted
this type of thing
projects denim and its upcoming sequel
the carnage and into the final verse and
its upcoming sequel but what does all
this mean for or see spider-man spin-off
which of those loose thread stories that
Sony used to lure him back to the
spider-man franchise look money
I mean bangs good at all rain total body
fuel sour apple flavored coenzymes and
PC EE aminos John please you're speaking
over the great Eric boss you can get 25
look at all the models bang that's
energy drink bang you look like them you
can buy a case it comes your keto coffee
flavors rainbow unicorn cotton candy
they got it all to be your best thing
and so thanks again to Benny energy for
sponsoring this video 25% off at band
energy Tommy's in the code new rock
stars 25 and follow the inventor of bang
on instagram at man energy I see John
bang 3 our assumption that third moments
that that movie will be a sinister six
movie villain Tom coming apart let this
have established potentially left alive
nacho for better call Saul is scorpion
hunter set photos on other Sony films
have shown Kraven catering trucks and
Kraven would be the perfect villain to
lead a manhunt for Peter Parker on
behalf of day jonah jameson
perhaps an adaptation Ravens last hunt
Tom Holland is also recently said that
the movies script is quote insane and we
broke down what they can mean in our
recent quarantine approved application
unbelievable
is already having another iconic Marvel
character like but then maybe Kraven in
the third film all right oh man 2029 the
post-credits scene of into the
spider-verse shell with spider-verse
plan it just went through Marvel and
animation to watch versions of these
characters that fans really loved and
wanna see me sure so when it comes to
this or see spider-man spin-off yeah he
separates sinister sticks movie tops the
list perhaps the 2014 behind Giamatti
statistics I'd rather watch that hey
watching in a freakin in with Kraven
Drive EP a burger out of the picture
setting the stage for a sinister six
story without Peter but it would be the
hero that story well I think Tom
Hollands spider-man 3 will also
introduce a new spider-man that Sony can
exert greater control over in future
spider-man movies post Tom Holland I'm
thinking we will meet a live-action
Miles Morales do exist in this movie
universe with Donald Glover playing
Aaron Davis in homecoming and missioning
uh nephew I don't want those weapons in
his neighborhood I got a nephew delivery
yes
I did when Stacy and Peters high school
and Avengers in game but that was just
an extra who gets web pattern skirts of
Hot Topic
but maybe part of the reason or see
parted ways with the amazing spider-man
franchise was an interest in gwen stacy
as a character beyond the death of one
stacy storyline that the amazing
spider-man 2 kind of rushed into that
movie but whatever this spin-off film is
it will likely be semi connected to the
MCU but not so much that Sony would have
to co-produce it with marble mark the
next three years ago the way I have
written for them too and Disney just
buys out all of Sony the way they did
for clocks and they no longer to debate
what is and it's not MCU candy because
everything is period with a relaunch of
Marvel's infinity saga starting with
Peter Parker surrogate daddy Ironman
video coming up soon followed by another
semi canonical overlook to Marvel film
The Incredible Hulk yes it happened and
it was actually pretty great watch along
with me every Friday on our discord
server by becoming a patron of new rock
stars at patreon.com slash new what you
want the spider-man spin-off film to be
follow me at eat a box follow new rock
stars and subscribed into rock stars
here on YouTube for break that's
everything Marvel thanks for watching
bad Eric Foss is smart cookie that one
is it me or is he gotten like funnier
over time feel like he's even freer to
just goof around now are you struggling
he's a really big drinking problem I
believe that he looks like he's really
not holding up worried very much I think
Joe gained drink some Bank now before we
talk about some of the spider-man
specific stuff great job Eric Foss once
again secondly editors don't point you
guys out enough you guys are excellent
at what you do and I love the fun
graphics he threw in there especially
with the old-timey aged film effect
never going back to the past I loved the
burrito metaphor you know my god that is
perfect that's exactly why I haven't
wanted a sinister 6 in the third
spider-man movie I'm not opposed to
sinister six
I'm not at all close to burritos I just
don't think the burrito six should be in
this next spider-man movie but the
theory bringing us a solo or a solo but
a spin-off of this isn't a sexist on
that man somehow setting that up I think
would be really
very cool very cool very cool if you
guys haven't seen our video talking
about the dead : news we didn't talk
about pretty good amount about some of
these things actually already we didn't
really explore the option of a
standalone sinister six movie but one
thing I did mention was for part three
if you do have Kraven the hunter as the
main villain or whomever that's cool one
thing that I think would be very
effective very impactful because let's
spider-man has to do slash Peter Parker
has to do in this next film is prove
that he did not kill Mysterio prove that
he is innocent and based off the way the
footage went down in that sequence where
he's looking at the news I would imagine
Mysterio is still alive to have altered
that footage so I think it would be neat
if somewhere towards the finale of the
movie or towards the end Mysterio is
still alive and he's able to prove
Mysterio still alive so that way he can
reclaim his innocence
which would make sense why someone like
Mysterio would ultimately want to team
up with other baddies so a sinister six
movie would be pretty cool and the idea
of that one not having a live-action
Peter Parker Tom Holland but having a
live-action Miles Morales working off of
that seed planted in homecoming honestly
that sounds way better than that being
spider-man 3 and I would totally check
that film out because spider-verse a
different type of medium animation but
sony knocked it out of the park with
that one they really have a great grip
on an understanding of Spider Glen and
also Miles Morales having them and there
could be very cool if it's captured from
the perspective of the sinister six and
debut spider-man as a bad guy I don't
know exactly know what they would do I
would hope that for the sinister six and
if there is a Spider Man character there
that they still keep the perspective on
the sinister six yeah that would be
pretty cool and that would be an
interesting way to do too for them to
expand on the recent wave of more nice
or villain oriented stories like that if
you got an ensemble piece that's kind of
antihero and you kind of get to see some
of our well-known hero right from the
opposite side I think that could be just
a cool dimension for these types of
movies and a way to justify jumping to a
sinister six movie right away somebody
like Drew Goddard is great with working
with ensembles and stuff like that which
you know you said about the old idea is
kind of the only enticing part I'm wary
of Hobart o or C just because of
you know the various of his films I've
seen but who knows man maybe this will
be the part where him and Kurtzman break
apart Kurtzman had the torque universe
and maybe Orsi will be the more
successful of the two with his
spider-man yeah either way I think it's
a great idea to introduce Miles Morales
specifically just because I mean we've
had a couple live action Gwen's not
spider-gwen
you could do them both in that movie but
I would definitely definitely want to
see a live action Miles Morales come out
because I feel like that's sort of the
last link to get to the big screen well
it's similar to how Avengers Assemble
had you know pretty much characters that
we've seen from the other solo films
they really expanded upon Hawkeye he was
pretty much the newest character in that
film if you have sinister six and if
they do decide to do a vulture Mysterio
as part of that group then you could
have scorpion who by the way I didn't
start better call Saul till the end of
last year then I am fully caught up on
the show now it's probably the best show
on television by the way and I love the
actor who plays nacho so he showed up I
was like wait a minute wait a minute but
if you had scorpion in there kind of
like how Hawkeye was in a brief moment
in Thor it is an actual character in the
Avengers and then you could have Morbius
and venom and then you can introduce a
brand new characters your sixth member
yeah or whoever may be the villain
spider-man 3 I don't know or maybe it's
shocker one of the shockers Joaquin
would buy and get him in there my god
you know names
yeah I am a quote yeah and both shockers
were in that movie devil both people in
the elevator look at that yeah all right
guys so what do you think about this
idea what do you care about more
happening in spider-man 3 having a Matt
Murdock character in there or or
she-hulk in there why not but I'm
obviously leaning towards one more than
the other or establishing a potentiality
for sinister six leave your thoughts
down below do you want a Jay jonah
Jameson solo spin-off movie yes I do
I kind of do we do it would be like
spotlight subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification valve make sure
you subscribe to new rockstars check us
on patreon weekly Q&A is TV show watch
alongs as well as several shows have
reaction highlights included last one
all these
Kameron French you guys should go check
out his Instagram Cameron's movie
reviews I wrote you a poem I think it's
my best one big day just wrote it guys
speak it while it's wrong I heard a
deleted line from Poe Dameron where he
said forget Finn
I want Cameron no my man I'm not talking
about Monaghan put that Joker on the
bench
Oscar ships mr. French let's get archaic
what's her name meaning Gaelic
definition not a straight position
because her name means crooked got gay
guys feeling wooded personality eclectic
communication is authentic got another
question what's her name meaning in
Celtic it means crooked nose you know I
got around that war with hoes I'm
talking about the ladies you Bing not an
actual watering hose but I'm sure from
time to time you do use a watering hose
I should really get off topic with this
watering hose but you know who don't get
off of him all his hot ass hoes Jack
said there's more room on that door Rose
she left him to froze when she said no
way Jack I'm one of Cameron's hoes
that's right people Cameron Celtic
crooked noses over a hundred years old
which makes sense cuz only old people
use a watering hose loves to watch our
reaction as he says lights camera action
follow my man out Instagram at Cameron's
movie reviews movies TV and wrestling
groovy PP nestling the read through his
posts like the ones you love the most
you'll never find yourself yawn but you
might find yourself on his front lawn
why cuz Moe's know he's got a brand new
watering hose take care of your lawn
Cameron Florida's a dangerous place